(mellow music)
- There's not a face for every culture,
every ethnicity, every race.
So when you're telling me that
I'm too dark to be Dominican,
show me what a Dominican looks like.
And then try to tell me that
I'm not Dominican enough,
because you're wrong.
I'm Dominican; I'm Black;
I'm an Afro-Latina;
and you can't tell me any different.
(upbeat music)
An Afro-Latina is simply a
person who just identifies
with their Blackness, that's it.
I'm a Black girl, and my family
is from Dominican Republic.
But people say I'm too
dark to be Dominican.
People say I can't be Latina.
Growing up there was no
one who looked like me.
I remember just being called charcoal.
I remember being called too dirty.
At one point, I stopped
saying I was Dominican.
My goal is simply to be
able to help the youth
feel comfortable in their skin and own it.
(speaking in foreign language)
Hello.
Most people know me as
MonicaStyleMuse over on YouTube,
Instagram, you name it.
I've been able to be extremely
successful as an Afro-Latina
in the beauty space.
This is one of my favorite eyebrow pencils
because the precision
just makes your brows,
you know I live for a brow lift.
I'm not the best makeup artist,
and never did I ever say I was,
but, I feel like if I can at
least just inspire other people
to just live in their own truth
regardless of what other people think.
- I know her cause I
follow her on Instagram.
- Oh, she likes me.
- I like her.
- I’m cool!
It took me maybe three
years to really find myself
and to be my own muse on my channel.
You can put this all over your face
to really bring the
moisture back into your face,
so you look refreshed.
One day I just decided, you know what,
I'm gonna be myself.
(speaking in foreign language)
At first when I started
speaking Spanish on my channel,
they were like, can you stop this?
Can you just make a separate channel?
And I said you know what, no.
This is who I am,
and it was the best decision
I've ever made for myself.
Being a Latina means knowing
that you have a culture
and a background and a story
that can't also be taken from you.
My audience is this sassy person
who is just so ready to take on
whatever the world throws at them.
They're gonna figure it
out one way or another,
and that's what I've done.
Even like thinking back to little Monica,
baby Monica was so timid.
She was so scared of the world.
I'm an adult now; you
can't really phase me.
(speaking in foreign language)
Which means, if my shine bothers
you, that's not my problem.
(gentle music)